WE REALLY ARE APPRECIATIVE OF
YOU COMING FORWARD.
>> Sandra: SOME HEALTH EXPERTS
FEAR LIFTING RESTRICTIONS TOO
SOON COULD RESULT IN A SURGE IN
NEW CASES.
WITHOUT EXPANDING TESTING, IT
WILL NOT BE SAFE.
AND A FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
DOCTOR, GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
SO YOU HEARD THE PRESIDENT’S
PLAN, THEY HAVE LAID IT OUT AND
NANCY PELOSI IS CRITICIZING IT
AS BEING TOO VAGUE.
IS IT THE RIGHT PLAN OBVIOUSLY
CONSIDERING THE FEARS OUT THERE
THAT THIS COULD BE TOO SOON?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I DON’T THINK
IT’S VAGUE.
I THINK IT’S VERY SPECIFIC IN
TERMS OF GATING AND THE PHASES
THAT YOU WOULD HAVE.
TWO WEEKS OF GATING WE ARE NOT
SEEING AN INCREASE OF CASES AND
ACTUAL DECLINING CASES, THEN
PHASE ONE WHERE YOU REOPEN GYMS
AND STADIUMS AND RESTAURANTS,
THEN PHASE TWO WHERE YOU OPEN UP
MORE THINGS LIKE BARS AND YOU
HAVE MORE OUTDOOR THINGS LIKE
PARKS OPENING.
THAT’S PRETTY SPECIFIC.
I HAVE SOME OTHER CONCERNS,
SANDRA.
AND I’M NOT THE ONLY ONE TO SAY
THIS, WE NEED MASSIVE TESTING TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE NOT SEEING
THE RESURGENCE THAT DR. FAUCI IS
TALKING ABOUT.
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO KNOW?
YOU DON’T WANT TO BE IN A
SITUATION WE’VE BEEN IN THE LAST
FEW WEEKS WILL BE ONLY FIND OUT
HOW MANY CASES THERE ARE
INDIRECTLY BY HOW MANY
HOSPITALIZATIONS WE GET WITH OUR
FACILITIES BEING OVERWHELMED.
WE NEED POINT-OF-CARE TESTING
WHERE WE CAN SAY YOU’RE SICK,
YOU HAVE IT.
NOT YOUR VERY SICK BEFORE WE CAN
TEST YOU.
YOU’RE SICK, YOU HAVE IT, WE CAN
DO POINT-OF-CARE TESTING WITH
THINGS LIKE THE ABBOTT PLATFORM
AND A ANTIBODY TESTS AND THE CDC
DIRECTOR REDFIELD TOLD ME THEY
ARE DOING THESE KINDS OF
SURVEILLANCES IN TEN DIFFERENT
STATES ALREADY BUT I WANT IT
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES WERE I
COULD SAY THIS IS A COMMUNITY
AND PEOPLE HERE HAVE IT ALREADY,
THEY ARE ALREADY OVER IT, THEY
CAN GO BACK TO WORK OR THEY
NEVER HAD IT.
WE NEED TO KNOW WHICH
COMMUNITIES ARE AT RISK IN WHICH
COMMUNITIES ARE GETTING OVER
THIS.
WE NEED THE TESTING TO BE ABLE
TO DO THAT AND THEN IN TERMS OF
THE PHASES THEMSELVES, I WOULD
POINT OUT THAT THERE ARE SOME
DOWNSIDES TO SOME OF THESE
ISSUES BECAUSE THERE’S ALWAYS
THE RISK IF YOU’RE IN A SPORTING
ARENA THAT PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
GET TOO CLOSE WHILE THERE GOING
TO ORDER A HOT DOG OR A BEER SO
IT’S VERY HARD TO KEEP SOCIAL
DISTANCING IN PLACE AND SOME OF
THESE PLACES INCLUDING
RESTAURANTS.
>> Sandra: VERY INTERESTING.
NANCY PELOSI IN HER OWN WORDS
SAID THIS AFTER THE PRESIDENT
ANNOUNCED HIS PLANS LAST NIGHT,
THE WHITE HOUSE DOES NOTHING TO
MAKE UP FOR THE PRESIDENT’S
FAILURE TO LISTEN TO THE
SCIENTISTS AND PRODUCE INDUSTRY
APPROVED NATIONAL RAPID TESTING.
EVEN THOUGH THE SURGEON
GENERAL WENT ON FOX AND FRIENDS
THIS MORNING, DEFENDING THESE
DECISIONS SAYING THEY ARE GOING
OVER THE NUMBERS EVERY HOUR OF
EVERY DAY.
HERE’S THE SURGEON GENERAL .
>> THIS VIRUS HAS HUMBLED ME,
HUMBLED THE TASK FORCE, HUMBLED
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
I CAN PROMISE YOU IN THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT THE
TASK FORCE IS GOING OVER DATA
FOUR HOURS A DAY EVERY SINGLE
DAY AND HAVING THE HUMILITY TO
SAY LOOK, WE THOUGHT IT WAS A,
NOW WE FIND OUT THAT IT’S B SO
LET’S CHANGE OUR RECOMMENDATIONS
SO THEY CAN BE AS SAFE AS
POSSIBLE.
>> Sandra: SO THERE HE WAS
ASSURING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
THEY ARE TAKING IN THE RIGHT
STEPS TO REOPEN THE ECONOMY BUT
AT THE SAME TIME KEEP EVERYONE
SAFE.
FINAL THOUGHTS, DR. SIEGEL ON
THE PROMISE OF THIS NEW DRUG,
MOVING MARKETS THIS MORNING.
AN EARLY PEEK AT DATA ON GILEAD
CORONAVIRUS DRUGS SUGGEST
PATIENTS ARE RESPONDING TO
TREATMENTS, SO THERE ARE REPORTS
THAT THEY ARE USING THIS DRUG ON
CORONAVIRUS PATIENTS AT A
HOSPITAL IN CHICAGO AND HAVING A
LOT OF SUCCESS WITH THIS.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THIS
AND IS THIS A GAME CHANGER?
>> I THINK IT’S A POTENTIAL
GAME CHANGER.
I INTERVIEWED DR. KHALIL WHO IS
IN CHARGE OF ALL OF THESE
CLINICAL TRIALS OUT OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF NEBRASKA IN
FEBRUARY.
HE WAS OPTIMISTIC BUT SANDRA, A
NEWS ORGANIZATION GETTING A
VIDEO OF SOME DOCTOR SAYING IT’S
WORKING ON THE WARDS THAT
UNIVERSITY OF CHICAGO IS HARDLY
SCIENCE.
WE NEED TO HAVE CLINICAL TRIAL.
WE DON’T HAVE THE RESULTS HE
HAD.
MAY BE PROMISING, BUT WE DON’T
EVEN KNOW WHEN TO USE THIS DRUG.
MY PREDICTION IS BY THE WAY THAT
IT WILL BE USEFUL BUT IT HAS TO
BE USED EARLY IN THE GAME BEFORE
ALL THE INFLAMMATORY EFFECTS WE
ARE SEEING AND ALL THE BLOOD
CLOTTING WE ARE SEEING.
BY THE TIME YOU ARE IN THE ICU,
IT’S PROBABLY TOO LATE FOR THIS
DRUG BUT THAT’S THE KIND OF
THINGS THE CLINICAL TRIALS WILL
TELL US.
WE DON’T HAVE ENOUGH INFORMATION
YOU HAVE TO BE GIVING IT A
RINGING ENDORSEMENT.
WE’VE GOT TO WAIT FOR THE
SCIENCE ON THIS.
>> Sandra: ALL RIGHT, YOU’VE
BEEN TAKING US THROUGH THIS AND